malgré les cris des larmes les promesses
internationales et les voeux pieux
rien n'y fait le problème des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre et pire en pire
c'est clair comme était menacée en effet
au lieu de diminuer comme on le
souhaitait léger es présent dans
l'atmosphère ont augmenté en moyenne de
1,5 pour cent par année depuis dix ans
et même de 2 % l'an dernier un record le
climat de la planète continuent donc de
se dérégler
essentiellement parce que la population
mondiale augmente et avec elle le
développement économique
l'accord de paris devait pourtant
permettre de limiter le réchauffement à
1,5 degré en 2005 mais au rythme actuel
il atteindra au moins trois degrés demie
6 avril pour maintenir le cap défini à
paris il faudrait donc une réduction de
55 % des ges d'ici 2030
un défi colossal et 3 à titre d'exemple
il faudrait d'ici 2030
l'inde abandonnent toutes ses centrales
au charbon que la chine et l'europe ne
vend plus que des véhicules neufs 100%
électrique et que les états unis
appliquent une taxe du carbone à la
grandeur du pays
absolument
le tout nouveau ministre canadien de
l'environnement reconnaît que le constat
de l'onu est inquiétant le canada a dit
que nous avons un cible pour 2030 et
nous d'avant surpasser sa cible mais
nous avons aussi dit que nous d'avant
faire les choses que le scientifique dit
le monde doit faire
le ministre n'a pas voulu s'avancer sur
la nouvelle cible possible de réduction
des ges au canada
ici norma grondin radio canada montréal